One of my favorite magicians is Karl Germain.
He had this wonderful trick...
...where a rosebush would bloom right in front of your eyes.
But it was his production of a butterfly that was the most beautiful.
"Ladies and gentlemen, the creation of life."
When asked about deception, he said this:...
"Magic is the only honest profession."
"A magician promises to deceive you and he does."
I like to think of myself as an honest magician.
I use a lot of tricks, which means that sometimes I have to lie to you.
Now, I feel bad about that.
But people lie every day.
Hold on.
Hey, where are you?
I'm stuck in traffic.
I'll be there soon.
You've all done it.
I'll be ready in just a minute, darling.
It's just what I've always wanted.
You look great!
Deception, it's a fundamental part of life.